this video was sponsored by
curiositystream and nebula check out
bonus content relating to this video on
my nebula page
in 2016 the juno spacecraft entered into
an orbit of jupiter and began sending
back information about its atmosphere
and magnetic field this was the first
time that a spacecraft had been put into
a polar orbit of jupiter meaning that
the probe saw every part of jupiter
including its poles as it orbited and
that meant we saw some things that we've
never seen before in particular juno
made a bunch of discoveries about
jupiter's polar regions
including
this you're looking at jupiter's south
pole in the infrared part of the
spectrum and a collection of beautiful
swirls in its atmosphere each one of
these is about 5 000 kilometers across
so the earth's moon would easily fit
inside each one and when these were
discovered it was kind of a total
surprise scientists knew there'd be
something at jupiter's poles but weren't
expecting
this to look at why it was surprising
let's quickly look at earth's atmosphere
and what happens over our poles
people who've watched the channel for a
long time will know what's coming next
because it's what i did my phd on it's
the stratospheric polar vortex
just when i thought i was out
they pulled me back in
this is a big donut of air several
thousand kilometers across in the middle
atmosphere that forms every winter in
both the northern and southern
hemispheres ultimately driven by the
temperature difference between the cold
polar night and the warm equator there's
obviously a lot more complexity to it
than that and i've made some videos
about some of those complexities but
basically it's just a circulation of air
around the wintertime pole in the middle
atmosphere caused by the temperature
difference between the wintertime pole
and the equator quite simple really but
earth is not alone in fact pretty much
every planet and moon that we know of
that has an atmosphere also has a polar
vortex and they're all a bit different
venus's thick atmosphere has a polar
vortex that's similar to earth's but
lasts all year long with a complicated
central circulation within the vortex
mars has a polar vortex that extends
much further down towards the surface
not what we see on earth at all and
saturn has one that's
hexagonal that's a long way on the scale
of atmospheric weirdness from earth's
kind of vanilla doughnut of rotating air
to saturn's
settlers of katan tile with all that
variety are these all really the same
phenomenon and what do we really mean
when we call something a polar vortex we
thought a lot about this when we wrote
the paper and we thought how do you
define polar vortex and then we thought
well let's split it up how did you find
polar that's not even very obvious how
do you define vortex
well just a spinny thing this is
professor dan mitchell at the university
of bristol who along with his co-authors
just published a paper reviewing all the
polar vortices we know about and tried
to make sense of what connects them all
if you break it down to it it's
constituent parts
then actually a vortex is is a is an air
mass that rotates around the central
point and so we've just vaguely put that
in as a definition and then said if it
appears in the polar region and sort of
leave
leave it up to you to understand what
that polar region really means in fact
in order to have a physics-based
definition dan had to make use of a
property of an atmosphere called its
rosby deformation radius which is just a
length it's a number that you can
calculate for earth for example in the
middle atmosphere it's a couple of
thousand kilometers so that basically
means
if you've got a rotating fluid say a
very large one on a planet if something
happens on one side of that fluid is it
felt on the other side
so a a counter example where it's not
the case is the earth's jet stream
if we get a wobble in one side of the
jet stream say over europe we won't
necessarily get one over the other side
if there is some influence from one side
to the other then we thought that
defines a polar vortex because that
means it's a coherent structure
if there's a wobble on one side
then you'll get it on the other side
this is really beautiful to me because
it's a wonderful example of how the laws
of physics are the same everywhere we
can describe how any atmosphere of any
planet or any moon behaves using the
same set of equations and each planet or
moon is unique because of the unique
combination of parameters of numbers
that we put into these equations but
they all obey the same laws they can all
be described using the same ideas like
the rosby defamation radius anyway i
digress using this definition with a
slight problem on saturn's moon titan
that we won't get into
you can construct a theory that
describes how polar vortices form and
behave on all planets and moons that's
what dan's review paper is all about so
what's going on with jupiter it was only
when juno arrived it's in polar orbit so
it circles around the poles and they
could look invisible and first of all
when you saw the images of the visible
they were just amazing you know
fascinating things and they gave a hint
of these huge polar vortices but it was
only when we looked in the infrared
which penetrated through the visible
layer to the deeper layer of jupiter
we saw these vortex clusters
and and every scientist just sort of put
up their hands and were like well what's
this we have no idea rather than just
one polar vortex like earth or mars or
saturn or well anything else we've seen
before jupiter has a cluster of them
each one is a circulation in the polar
region within the length scale of the
rosby deformation radius for jupiter and
so a coherent structure
each one of these is a polar vortex so
at jupiter it does have a central polar
vortex still
so that there's a central polar vortex
and it's surrounded by slightly smaller
polar vortices and that creates a
cluster how is that different from the
other polar vortices
well
it's stable like the other polar
vortices
but we do see migration of what's going
on in jupiter so we see some some polar
vortices from closer to the equator
migrate up and then just push their way
into these clusters and that forms a new
configuration but that central polar
vortex is always very stable and present
so that's more analogous to the other
planets jupiter was what motivated me to
write the review paper it's just a
natural
polar vortex which you couldn't imagine
unless you saw it and that's why i
really
loved jupiter's polar vortex jupiter has
a cluster of polar vortices at each pole
unexpected and there's plenty of
unanswered questions about them but
ultimately they're explainable using the
same laws of physics that we use here on
earth to describe our polar vortex
this is a polar vortex just as much as
this is but here's the really cool bit
there's probably even weirder stuff out
there and we may just be about to find
out about it i would like to see if
there are polar vortex clusters or
even something more exciting on
exoplanets
that's where you know that's where it's
really interesting and that's what's
great about the recent launch of the
james webb telescope we won't be able to
directly observe polar vortex with that
telescope it's not powerful enough but
we'll get some pretty cool spectra out
of it and we might be able to say hey
there looks like there's some clusters
on this planet or or actually there's
something
even more fun that we hadn't even
considered
just like when we discovered
the jupiter polar vortices and we hadn't
considered it
so i mentioned that there was a slight
complication with dan's classification
of polar vortices on titan saturn's moon
dan talks about this and a bunch of
other fascinating topics which
unfortunately i just couldn't fit into
this video in an extended interview on
nebula you've almost certainly heard of
nebula before it's the streaming service
owned by a huge collection of
educational youtubers including me where
we upload additional content that
wouldn't play nicely with the youtube
algorithm as well as original content
such as next level world building and
the feature length alaska's silent
summer from wendover productions unlike
youtube nebula has no adverts whatsoever
on its pages or anywhere in its videos
instead you just pay a subscription fee
then get split up between us creators
supporting our work except you can get
completely free access to nebula if you
sign up to our partner's curiosity
stream and why wouldn't you if you've
watched this video this far you're
clearly a curious person and so would
love the thousands of documentaries on
curiosity stream in particular you may
enjoy destination jupiter about the juno
mission or zenith advances in space
exploration or perhaps something about
economics or military history or sperm
whales there's just so much to choose
from if nebula is the best of small
scale indie productions then curiosity
stream is the best of big scale
professional productions so it makes
perfect sense to get the best of both
worlds in a bundle which you can do at
curiositystream.com
simon clark link below which also gives
you a 26
discount that means it's 1.24 a month
for access to all of this and all of
this
it's possibly the best investment you'll
ever make in your online experience and
in supporting educational video that's
curiositystream.com simon clark with
thanks to curiositystream and nebula for
sponsoring this video
thank you for watching the video right
the way to the end i tried something a
little different with this i wanted to
go for a slightly broader audience than
normal so this is a very complicated
topic that i tried to tell as simply as
possible let me know what you thought in
the comments thank you to dan for taking
part in this video and for pointing me
to his paper the interview we did was so
interesting i think there's probably
going to be a couple of other videos
based on it going forward so you've not
seen the last of them whereas if you
enjoyed this video please do pop it a
like and share it with people that you
think may also find it interesting if
you're staying here on youtube then
here's some recommended viewing next and
that just leaves me to say thank you
again for watching i'll see you in the
next one